[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN DUFF: My
name's Brian Duff,
and I lead the Android
Context Team at Google.
And I'm really thrilled
that you're all here today
and interested to learn more
about how you can use Awareness
and Nearby to make your
applications more contextual.
So all of us experience
the world around us
with our five senses.
We see, we smell, we hear,
we touch, and we taste.
And we react to our
world based on what we
experience with those senses.
And as we go about our life,
we encounter many devices
in our home, at our place
of work, on the bus,
and on the train.
These devices that we
have are really amazing.
They have a huge array of
sensors and capabilities.
And just like us, they can sense
many things about their world.
They have a high resolution
camera so they can see.
They have an audio system so
they can hear and make sound.
They have GPS so they can
know where they are anywhere
on the planet.
They have a gyroscope, an
accelerometer, and a compass
so they can know how they're
oriented and moving in space.
All of these capabilities are
what make this a smartphone.
And these capabilities can
also make our applications
much smarter about
what the user is
trying to achieve and
accomplish in our applications.
However, as an
application developer,
sometimes making sense
of all of these signals
is harder than it
should be, especially
trying to get a more deeper and
nuanced understanding of what
the user is doing.
So our mission on
the Context Team
is to try to take away as much
of this complexity as we can
and to make it as easy for
you as possible to understand
the context of the user, and
also to detect and communicate
between devices
that are around you.
Last year at Google I/O, we
announced the Awareness API.
So Awareness provides two
powerful but simple concepts.
The Snapshot API lets you query
and poll contextual information
around devices at any time.
And the Fence API lets
you set up the conditions
that your application is really
interested in and trigger
behavior, even when
your application is
running in the background.
There are many APIs in
Android that you can
use to get this information.
But the real power
of the Awareness API
lies in how you can combine
various different signals
together to get a really
nuanced understanding of what
the user is doing.
For example, maybe
it's not enough just
to know that I'm at
a specific place,
that I'm at the coffee shop.
But knowing what it is
that I'm doing there,
that I'm standing
in line, can be
really useful in providing a
better experience for my users.
Maybe by knowing that
I'm standing in line,
my app can tell me, hey,
instead of waiting to be served,
you can just order your
coffee directly from the app.
And then I can go sit down, hack
some code in in Android Studio,
and wait for my
coffee to be made.
So you can see that sort
of combining these signals
together can provide
richer, suggestive,
and predictive
experiences for users.
One thing that's
hard when you try
to build this kind of
experience is doing it
in a way that's as cognizant
of the user's battery power
and resources as possible.
So another great strength
of the Awareness API
lies in optimizing
system resources
as best as we can to achieve
these kinds of things.
Several years ago, we
started the Nearby project.
We had a really
simple aim in mind
with Nearby, which was to allow
you to walk up and use devices
in your life just the
same way that you walk up
and interact with
people in your life.
We were hoping that by
building this technology,
and by building
simple APIs around it,
we would enable a
whole new generation
of proximity-enabled
applications.
So I've got to admit something.
When we first built
this technology,
it was actually really,
really annoying.
So we tried to use sounds to
detect the devices that are
in the same room as each other.
And the early prototypes we
built made this incredibly
noisy, screechy
sound that totally
irritated all the teams
that were sitting around us.
So we took a step back,
and we worked really hard
on perfecting this technology,
and we added radio technology
as well.
And we encapsulated all of this
in a really straightforward API
called Nearby Messages.
Nearby Messages
allows you to publish
small amounts of information
to the devices around you
and transfer that
information via the cloud.
But Nearby and Awareness
have one basic limitation.
In order to use them, your
application must be installed.
Now that doesn't really meet the
goal of having people walk up
to things and just use them.
Sometimes the best
possible experience
that we can provide to users
is in a site or an application
that they don't even know
about, let alone have installed.
While you're here in Mountain
View, if you still have time,
I really recommend going to
visit the Computer History
Museum on Shoreline.
They have a wide variety of
exhibits from the early days
of computer science.
And whenever I go
there, and I stand
in front of one
of those exhibits,
I really want to
know more about it.
And of course I could read the
little sign that's on there,
or I could scan a
QR code, or I could
do an image search, or type
a short URL into my phone.
But it turns out
the Computer History
Museum have a really great app.
And in that app, there's
a wealth of information
about each exhibit.
There's even an
audio tour that I
can use to learn more from
the experts about each item.
So I didn't know about this
app until fairly recently.
But I really think
it's a great experience
if you can go to the
Computer History Museum
and just stand in front
of one of those exhibits,
and your phone can tell you,
hey, there's an app available,
help you to install it,
and take you directly
to the place in the app that's
relevant for the thing you're
standing next to.
Last year at Google
I/O, we introduced
Nearby Notifications,
which is a technology that
allows you to attach sites
and applications to real world
physical objects using
Bluetooth Low Energy beacons.
So I'm thrilled
that you're all here
and that you want to make
applications more contextual.
And I have three senior
engineers from the team here
who are going to talk about best
practices for using these APIs.
And we're really happy to
announce some new features here
at Google I/O.
So to get started,
I'd like to introduce
Ryan Bavetta, who
is going to talk
about Nearby Notifications.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN BAVETTA: Thanks.
Hey, my name's Ryan Bavetta.
I'm a member of the
Nearby Notifications Team.
Like Brian said, we introduced
Nearby Notifications at I/O
last year, and it's been a
lot of fun seeing what you
guys have been making with it.
Today I'm going
to do an overview
of Nearby Notifications.
We'll talk about
some of the features
we've announced
within the past year.
And then we'll show you how
you can make your own messages.
Brian talked about
how we can make
these really compelling
experiences that are based
on contextual information.
But one of the
challenges we have
is how do we start
this experience.
Like you said, if the user
can skip the line for coffee
by using your app, how do
we suggest this app to users
without them having to type
the query into the search box?
Nearby Notifications provides
a link for Android users
to jump start this
interaction and jump straight
to the relevant page within your
app, instant app, or website.
Depending on your message's
relevance and performance,
we may, for example, light up
the Nearby Quick Settings tile,
display the
notification, display
the message in the
Nearby list view,
or raise a min or low
priority silent notification.
So let's see what
this might look like.
The other day, I was
at the Conservatory
of Flowers in San Francisco.
They have all these
interesting plants,
tons of flowers from
all over the world.
They have these great
signs next to the plants
that say the species name
and to find more information,
visit this website.
Now you could take
out your phone,
type in the URL
www.conservatoryofflowers.com,
dot org--
dot com goes somewhere else--
slash lowland.
But wouldn't it be
great if instead you
got this link to jump straight
to the content you want?
This provides more
information about the plants
in that gallery.
What could be better than this,
if it provided information
about the particular plant
you're standing in front of?
Now this kind of installation
is ambitious, but it's possible.
The finer the context,
the richer the experience
we can provide.
Now looking a little later
into this tree's life cycle,
if you're at the lumber
department of your local home
improvement store,
and you're trying
to decide between a 1x6, or a
2x6, or a cedar plank, pine--
it would be really
great if there
were an associate nearby--
we can provide a link
to page an associate
for that particular department.
That would be cool.
Another interesting use case
we found is with Device Setup.
Right now, when you buy a
Chromecast and plug it in,
we provide this
notification to allow
you to jump straight into
the app to set up the device.
If you don't have the
app, the Google Home app,
it brings you to the
Play Store, where
you're offered the
opportunity to install the app
and then continue right into
the right part of the app
to continue the setup.
Another interesting use
case is with instant apps.
There's a demo today in Dome
C at the Instant App booth--
so check that out later--
where they have a
little birdhouse.
The birdhouse is a stand-in
for an actual home for sale,
and it's advertising
a link to the detail
page of the instant app.
This is an amazing way
to get people access
to the rich content that
is deep inside your app
without the user having to
actually install the app.
So how do all these
scenarios work?
These use cases rely on the
phone detecting a Bluetooth Low
Energy beacon nearby.
Beacons are typically
small battery powered units
like this, but
they could also be
devices acting as beacons,
such as the Chromecast we
talked about.
What we do is join
the code broadcast
from the beacon to the text
that you'd like to be displayed.
But we don't want
to show messages
to uninterested parties.
So targeting is
really important.
Over the past year, we've
introduced several ways
so that you can
target and fine tune
the context of your
message to only show it
to these interested people.
We've introduced targeting
for time of day, day of week,
app install state-- that's
whether your app is installed
or not--
and we're announcing today
distance targeting, which
is the distance to the beacon.
This, alongside good
placement of your beacons,
helps make sure you're
targeting the right devices.
Bad interactions, like messages
that go ignored or muted,
may be reasons that
we may not show
your messages a notification.
Targeting the right
users can sometimes
involve stopping the broadcast.
For example, device
setup messages are great,
but if your device hasn't been
set up within about 15 minutes,
the user probably isn't going to
be setting it up anytime soon.
So you should stop
the broadcast.
Let's talk about the
text of your message.
When deciding how to
phrase your message,
it's really important
to be concise.
You don't have a lot of
characters available.
We found that about 40
is the maximum where
you can ensure that your
message is displayed entirely.
You should use strong context.
In this case, we're
looking for users that
are waiting in line to order.
And we should make it
clear what will happen when
the user taps on the message.
In this case, the user will
view a menu or place an order.
Contrast this with
a message like
come inside our store
or sale going on now.
These messages are likely
targeted to uninterested users,
and the user doesn't
know what will happen
when they tap on the message.
If you want to
test an attachment,
make sure to create the
message in debug mode.
Debug mode messages only
show on debug mode devices.
[CROWD CHEERING] Oh, we're not--
is that for me?
Turning on debug
mode on your device
also enables
detailed bug reports,
which are really
helpful when debugging.
Now how to add
messages to beacons.
There are two ways.
The first way, the beacon can
broadcast the URL directly
and will automatically pick
up the title and the fave icon
from the destination web page.
This is the easiest
way to get started.
But you won't be able to set
targeting for your message,
like time of day or distance.
To do that, you can have
your beacon broadcast an ID
and then tie that ID to the
message using the Beacon Tools
app in the Beacon Dashboard.
This message also allows
you to specify an app intent
to be launched.
Both of these methods allow
you to specify a URL that
launches an instant app.
For details of the setup
process, check out our website.
Again, there's a demo
today in the Dome C.
So be sure to check that out.
Now back to Brian.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN DUFF: Thanks, Ryan.
So we've seen with
Nearby Notifications
that you can enable
contextual experiences,
even if your application
is not installed.
Once your application
is installed,
there are a wide variety
of contextual signals
that your application
can trigger behavior on.
And to talk about this, Payam
Pakzad from the Awareness Team
is going to go into more
detail about Awareness.
[APPLAUSE]
PAYAM PAKZAD: Thanks, Brian.
My name is Payam, and
I'm the technical lead
for Awareness API.
So as you all know, Google
offers a rich collection
of contextual signals
via various APIs.
These include things like
fused location provider,
activity recognition, place
detection, geofencing,
Nearby Messages, as well as
a lot of information signals
about the state of the device,
whether screen is on or off,
Wi-Fi scans, and so on.
So while on the surface
these signals all
look quite different in the
way that they are produced,
they actually-- each one of
them tells you a different piece
of the common story about the
context of the user, where
they're at, what they're doing,
what's around them, and so on.
So this common theme is
rather lost in the way
that developers today,
without Awareness,
would have to collect these
separate pieces of information
from various APIs
and put them together
to get the full
contextual picture.
So last year, we
introduced Awareness API,
which offers a common
and simple to use
interface to access all
these contextual signals
and to seamlessly combine
them in a way that gives you
a more powerful experience.
What's more, actually
Awareness does
this in a manner
that's power optimized,
and it manages its own impact
on battery life and data usage.
So in a sentence for
us, Awareness API
is a unified sensing
platform, enabling apps
to be aware of all aspects of
a user's context, while still
managing system health for you.
Well, we currently offer the
following contextual signals
covering different aspects
of a user's context,
including things like where
they are with location
and semantic places,
what's around them
with nearby beacons, temporal
context with semantic times,
things like whether it's a
weekend or afternoon, what
they're doing with activities,
and interesting device
states like whether
headphone is on or not,
as well as interesting
information
about the ambient conditions,
weather in particular.
As Brian mentioned,
Awareness offers access
to these signals in two ways.
Our Fence API gives a
callback style access,
while our Snapshot API gives a
unified polling style access.
As far as Awareness
Fences go, you
can think of them as a
generalization of geofences.
You actually get a callback
when a specific condition
on a user's overall
contextual state is met.
This is especially powerful,
because now you can easily
combine these various
and disparate signals
into a single custom made
and semantically meaningful
condition that's actually custom
made for your app and your use
case.
I'll show the power
of this in an example
in the following few slides.
So suppose you are
writing an app that's
interested in the
event that the user is
close to a particular place
of interest on a sunny weekend
or holiday morning.
So just think for a
minute about all the steps
that you would have to take
to make something like this
to happen.
And here it is, how easy it
is to do this with Awareness.
You can first set up
an Awareness time fence
for the event that it
is weekend, similarly
one for event that is holiday,
and another for event that
is morning.
All of these, by the
way, are localized
to your current location.
You set up another
Awareness location fence
which is around the
place of interest
that you're interested in.
Once you have these
fence objects,
you can combine them via
Awareness fence language
in a very natural way.
You can almost read the sentence
as this is the event that it's
weekend, or holiday,
and it's morning,
and you're near that
particular place of API.
If you're interested in
more than a single place
of interest, you
can just as easily
extend this API by passing in
a collection of location fences
and use AwarenessFence.or
of all these things.
Once you have your
fences set up,
you have to register
it with Awareness.
And the way you do
it is you create
a fence update request object.
You need to pass in a fence key
that identifies the fence you
are interested in and a
pending intent on which you're
listening for the
trigger events.
And you finally register
it in the system.
At this point, you are ready
to receive trigger events.
Your receiver may look
something like this.
Notice that multiple
fences can be
registered against the
same pending intent.
So you'll have to check that the
fence key that you're receiving
trigger event on is the one
that you're interested in
and the current state is the
one that you're reacting to.
In my example, I
mention weather.
So you can access that just as
easily with our Snapshot API
with a single line.
So this gives you
the current weather
at the current location
that you're in.
Now I want to emphasize that
Awareness not only makes
doing all this very
simple, it actually
does it in a way that's power
and resources efficient.
So for example, in this
scenario that I just mentioned,
Awareness will cache
and store information
about the local weather
conditions, as well as
weekend and holiday models.
And you'll share it across
all the apps on your device
that they're interested.
So this will save on using
unnecessary network calls.
Another facet of this
is that Awareness
uses a smart evaluation
algorithm on the combined
fences, so that contexts
that are costlier to produce
are not produced until
they are actually needed.
So since last year,
we've actually
added some great new context
to make the Awareness
API even more powerful.
In particular, we've added
some semantic time context
conditions to our time fence.
Some of these I already
talked about in the example.
In addition to things
like parts of day,
and weekends, and
holidays, you can actually
now create conditions, fences,
around the solar times, that
is sunrise and sunset.
And I want to emphasize
again that these are set up
at the location that you're in.
So Awareness takes care of
updating the actual values
as the device moves to
different locations.
Our Snapshot API is
just as easy to use.
It gives you very quick
access to a fresh sample
of all the signals
that you're offering,
like places, weather,
beacon states, and so on.
So since last year that we
launched our API to public,
many of you have
started using Awareness
in very creative ways.
And I wanted to spend
a couple of minutes
to showcase a couple of
interesting use cases
by our partners.
The first example is
Stocard card assistant,
that I think in the last
session you actually heard
a little bit about as well.
So this is an app that lets the
users digitalize their loyalty
and rewards cards and stores
them in a digital wallet
format.
So what they found was
that users often actually
forget to use their loyalty
cards at the shopping
point at the moment
that they need to do it.
So they've used the combination
of Awareness fences, Awareness
context, to come up with a way
to estimate the exact moment
that users need to be
accessing these things,
and remind them with
a single click access
to pull up this thing.
Another great example is
QuickBooks Self-Employed.
And this is an app that helps
users track business expenses
for tax deduction purposes.
And they use a combination
of Awareness context
to accurately estimate the
business related mileages.
And as you can imagine,
this is a hard problem.
And you can only
get a good picture
by combining a different set
of contexts at the same time.
In the area of
digital fashion, this
is an app called Coded Couture
by Ivyrevel, which actually
creates a unique and
personalized design based
on a user's daily life.
So what they do is that they use
Awareness signals like places,
weather, and activity,
and translate them
in a creative way to fashion
designs for personalized
dresses.
So with that, I'd like
to hand it back to Brian.
You can find a lot
more information
and examples about our APIs
at our developers site.
And please come talk to
us about how we can make
Awareness work better for you.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN DUFF: Thanks, Payam.
So with Awareness,
you can really
trigger contextual
experiences that
take advantage of a bunch
of different signals,
combine them together in a way
that preserves battery power.
One example of context that
we think is really important
is proximity to other devices.
Since we announced the Nearby
Messages API a couple of years
ago, we've been really
impressed by the things
that people have built with it.
We've seen
applications that allow
you to explore your world.
We've seen applications
which allow
you to connect with the
people closest to you
in your life and share
things with them.
And we've also seen examples
of second screen experiences
and games taking
advantage of this API
to do really cool things.
We've also had a lot of
feedback from developers
about the kinds
of things that you
would like to see in the future
versions of the Nearby API.
And we've been
working really hard,
especially over the
last year, on bringing
some of these things to life.
And so I'm really, really
excited to introduce
Varun Kapoor, who
is going to talk
about how we're taking the next
generation of Nearby's APIs
offline.
[APPLAUSE]
VARUN KAPOOR: Why?
Why does it take me
more than one click
to share an article I'm reading
with my coworker who is seated
two feet away from me?
Why does it take more
than one click for me
to share the image search
results of poker hand rankings
with my poker group
every Friday night?
Well, let's raise
the stakes, ha, ha,
and set a slightly
more elaborate theme.
I'm in downtown SF, where
finding parking on the street
is rough even on a good day.
And then I see this.
It's after 5:00 PM, but it's
the 31st user of the year.
But it's a leap year.
But the stock market
was down today.
Do I park it or not?
Ah, I don't know.
I look across the street,
and I see five driveways
sitting empty, waiting
to be parked in.
I also remember that I
have an app on my phone
that lets people rent
out their driveways.
As luck would have it,
I'm in an area of SF
where I have a weak cell signal.
So as I wait for the long
round trips to the suburbs,
back and forth, back and forth,
I sense a darkness in the force
as I feel the sound of
the last chocolate eclair
at my favorite bakery
getting sold out.
It's too late.
Why, why could these houses not
just advertise the availability
and rates of their driveways,
so my phone could scan for them,
and query all of
them, and book the one
that makes more sense for me in
a completely offline fashion?
Taking it one step further,
if I'm late getting back,
why can't these
houses then query
my car, which will
tell them that I'm just
a block away, so I can avoid
being penalized or towed?
I'll tell you why.
Because implementing
these features entails
dealing with the vagaries
of Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
across the cross product
of A, the range of Android
OS versions out there, and
B, the variety of hardware
out there.
What these apps back then needed
was a reliable performance
proximity platform
that abstracts away
all this complexity
and leaves them free
so they can focus on
just adding the features
that matter to their users.
Now at this point, I think we
all know where I'm heading.
And there can be
only one thought
racing through all your minds.
This guy has got one rocking do.
Well, that is kind of you
to say and relatively true.
Allow me to be a
cautionary tale.
This, boys and girls,
is what happens
when you spend a year
working on building
exactly this kind of platform.
The radios have
commanded their sacrifice
in the form of my
hair and my tears.
Oh, so many tears.
OK, now that we have established
the big bat of our story,
it's time for our heroine to
come riding in to save the day.
Nearby Connections
is the next step
in the evolution of
Google's Nearby API,
an API that started
with Nearby Messages
as its vivant offering, but
which also quickly limited
its own reach by A, requiring
a connection to the internet,
and B, providing a
programming model that
has proven to be clunky
in all but the most
simple of cross
device interactions.
Unix doesn't provide a pub/sub
API as its lowest level
abstraction over the network.
It provides sockets.
And now so does Nearby.
In a nutshell,
Nearby Connections
enables the advertising and
discovery of nearby devices,
as well as high-bandwidth
low-latency encrypted data
transfers between these devices
in a fully-offline P2P manner.
It achieves this by
using a combination
of classic Bluetooth,
BLE, and Wi-Fi hotspots.
And it leverages the strengths
of each while supplementing
their respective weaknesses.
For instance, Bluetooth
has low connection latency,
but also provides low bandwidth.
Wi-Fi hotspots have slightly
higher connection latency,
but also provide much
higher bandwidth.
So what we do is we
connect over Bluetooth
and start transferring
data instantly.
But in the background, we
also bring up a Wi-Fi hotspot.
And when that's
ready, we seamlessly
transfer your connection
from Bluetooth
to Wi-Fi with absolutely no work
required by the app developer.
With that, let's look at the
flow of the key parameters
of the API.
An advertiser calls
startAdvertising,
and some time
later, a discoverer
calls startDiscovery.
Soon enough, the
discoverer is alerted
to the advertiser's
presence by means
of the onEndpointFound callback.
If the discoverer
is interested, they
can call requestConnection.
This is the end of the
asymmetric part of the API.
And from here on, everything
is completely symmetric.
Both sides get an
onConnectionInitiated callback
that gives them
an authentication
token they can use to
verify that they are indeed
talking to each other.
Upon out-of-band
verification, they
can both either call accept
or reject connection.
And when each side gets
the other's response,
we invoke the
onConnectionResult callback.
At this point, the connection is
either established or it's not.
From here, either
side can send payload
by calling the
sendPayload method.
This leads to the
other side getting
the onPayloadReceived callback,
followed by both sides getting
a series of
onPayloadTransferUpdate
callbacks up until the transfer
reaches the final state
of success or failure.
Finally, either side can
disconnect at any time,
and that leads to the
other side getting
the onDisconnected callback.
Aside from that,
there's a couple
of more concepts in the API.
We support three
kinds of payloads.
Bytes, these are byte
arrays of up to 32k,
and they are typically used
for sending metadata control
messages.
Files, these represent files
of the device's storage,
and we make sure
that we transfer
from the application to
the network interface
with a minimal amount of copying
across process boundaries.
And streams, this is good for
when you need to generate data
on the fly, and you
don't know the final size
up front, as is the case
with recorded audio or video.
As I mentioned earlier, we
use multiple radio techniques
to advertise, discover,
and establish connections.
And the combinations
of interactions
of these techniques are
qualified in our strategies.
Strategies are named for how
far they'll cause their net
to try and find a nearby device
and what kind of connection
topology they will enable.
And right now, we have two
of them, P2P_Star b star
and P2P_Cluster.
As the names might
suggest, P2P Star
makes sense for when you
want to enforce a star
network with a one-to-end
connection topology.
And P2P Cluster
makes sense when you
want to allow for slightly
looser end-to-end connection
topologies.
For example, a classroom
app where the teacher
wants to host a quiz for all the
students, that would probably
be best mounted over P2P Star,
with the teacher as the one
advertiser and the students
as the end discoverers.
And the same classroom
app could have
a mode that allows
students to break out
into ephemeral project groups.
This mode, where
students want to drift
in and out of multiple
groups, would be best served
with P2P Cluster.
Now let's see how all
this can be put together
in an undoubtedly
harmless mock application.
In a world where the machines
have not yet taken over,
and you feel compelled
to write a fun
little app to make a collection
of drones self-assimilate.
"But Varun," I hear
a voice ring out
in concern, "Why would
I want to do that?"
That's for the machines
to know and for humanity
to eventually find out.
For now, let's
just let this fly.
So as I was saying,
in that world,
since we want every drone to
see every other drone nearby,
we'll make every drone advertise
and discover at the same time.
Because we want them to exchange
some small control information
before making any larger
decisions, like what
to do with these
puny humans, we'll
make them instantly connect upon
discovery, often of advertiser.
And we'll have both sides auto
accept the connection, like so.
Once they are connected,
that short control message
we spoke about could be
modeled as a bytes payload.
In our case, we'll, let's say,
perform a quick leader election
algorithm, words we
will surely live to rue.
And finally, the leader can
send a stream payload back
to the follower that
allows sending constantly
changing updates about
discovering location
so they can move in lock
step with military precision.
What could possibly go wrong?
Now that was the simple
base case of two drones.
Applying mathematical induction
and generalizing to end
is left as an exercise
for the reader.
But by and large,
your end result
should look something like this.
At this point,
Brian has insisted
that I assure all of you
that I absolutely do not
have an army of
preprogrammed drones sitting
in my garage, armed and ready
to take flight at my slightest
whim.
So move along folks.
Nothing to see here.
While we wait for the day that
our benevolent robots will
grace us with their
cold, metallic probes,
we have some slightly
less bone-chilling uses
of Nearby Connections
spotted in the wild.
The Weather Channel is
using Nearby Connections
to build a pretty
darn cool offline
mesh to help spread
urgent weather updates
and warnings, especially in
the wake of natural disasters.
Sendanywhere is a
South Korean app
that allows sharing
files intelligently
in the most efficient
manner possible,
regardless of whether
you're online or not.
And they're using
Nearby Connections
for their offline modality.
Pocket Casts have been a great
partner for Nearby Messages.
And they now want
to enable people
sharing and discovering podcasts
in a completely offline manner.
For example, when you're
stuck in an aircraft
and are looking to
cloud, so what's
your options for entertainment?
GameInsight is a
leading game developer,
and they're using
Nearby Connections
to not only find nearby
players, but also to run
their games completely offline.
Again, being stuck in the inside
of an aircraft comes to mind.
Hotstar is India's fastest
growing streaming network.
And they're using
Nearby Connections
to allow offline sharing of
downloaded movies and TV shows.
So you don't need to have
access to the internet.
You only need access
to a friend who does.
And finally, Android TV is about
to launch a new remote control
app where they use Nearby
Connections to not only set up
your new Android
TV and configure
it to be on your Wi-Fi
network, but also to serve
interactive second stream
content in a streaming fashion.
Oh, and before I go,
there is one more thing.
That AP&P, Pay & Park, idea
I spoke about back there--
whichever one of you out
here makes your billions
by bringing that to life,
please at least send me a
postcard from your
private island
so I'll know that
this was not in vain,
and this happened
for a good cause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN DUFF: Thanks, Varun.
I'm really nervous about
these killer robots.
But I'm sure it's
all going to be OK.
So the Nearby Connections API is
going to be available, really,
in a couple of weeks in a
new version of Google Play
services, and we're really
excited to see what you're all
going to build with that.
Please keep giving us feedback
about the kinds of things you'd
like us to do with Nearby.
We're really excited
about your use cases,
and we want to make
the API better.
There's a wealth of
information on our developer
site about all of our
APIs, Awareness and Nearby.
There's a bunch of examples,
sample apps, reference
informantation.
And please join
our mailing list.
We'll send you updates when
the APIs are available.
And I just want to say a
big Thank You to all of you
for coming here.
I think we can build
really great apps together.
And thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]